on reste en loir et cher avec une
première dans le département la
vaccination des seniors en dehors des
ehpad une quarantaine de pensionnaires
des résidences autonomie du cis du
blésois ont reçu leur première injection
du vaccin
kaiser un moment attendu par des
pensionnaires qui ne peuvent pas se
déplacer vers les centres de vaccination
hélène chapelet avant d'administrer le
vaccin pfizer il faut incorporer
délicatement de l'eau pour préparation
injectables un travail méticuleux
obligatoire que sont en train de
réaliser ces deux infirmières elle
prépare des seringue individuel pour
vacciner 31 des quarante neuf
pensionnaires de la résidence lumière à
blois
pendant ce temps là dans le couloir
certains patientent déjà c'est le cas de
jeanne 99 ans qui prend cette
vaccination avec beaucoup de recul
d'accord durant la journée les
consultations et les injections se sont
donc enchaînées
geneviève 84 ans et la prochaine
patiente elle a posé ses bagages depuis
sept ans au sein de cette résidence non
médicalisés et pour elle ne pas avoir à
se déplacer dans le centre ville de
blois pour se faire vacciner est un vrai
plus c'est une très bonne initiative
parce que pour nous c'est pas facile de
se déplacer aurait fallu prendre le bus
et ont demandé des nous emmène premier
objectif c'est de faciliter la vie des
patients leur faciliter l'accès aux
vaccins qui n'ont pas à se déplacer sur
un centre de vaccination est donc c'est
plus facile et deuxième objectif c'est
de désengorger le centre de vaccination
à blois l'espace jorge semprun et puis
troisième objectif c'est aussi de
montrer combien cette vaccination elle
est importante
aujourd'hui on encore des personnes qui
sont hésitantes qui ont des doutes qu'on
les inquiétudes vont vouloir montrer au
fond que c'est très simple et les
inciter à pouvoir eux aussi accéder aux
vaccins dans une prochaine étape comme
ailleurs cette vaccination est gratuite
et non obligatoire
les secondes injections du vaccin pfizer
devrait avoir lieu dans les mêmes
conditions d'ici quelques semaines